no TV show had been done in imax before  so at first it was just like oh my god I  can't believe each other it's a whole  different way of viewing things why my  exes and you get like a real huge Santa  Maura experience I think it's just gonna  be insane please help me in welcoming  the star and we're in mice and David and  enjoy the show that was an amazing  experience watching on the big screen  like that was like I was watching it for  the first time got to see sweat beads  didn't even know that existed you can't  compare a 70 inch screen to a massive  imax rain there's just nothing like what  to actually see it on the big screen was  just  12 Game of Thrones fans please just get  off your couches and come see Game of  Thrones in imax and get a preview of  season 5 as well